سنوار يسحب إسرائيل، دعنا نقول لحظة
الحقيقة هي أننا على أهبة الاستعداد، نعم، هذا واضح لنا جميعا
أنه يلعب معنا جميعًا في هذه المرحلة وأنا أطلب منك ذلك
نفسي عندما أسمع جميع أنواع الإحاطات القادمة
من الجيش والجهاز الأمني ​​الذي وصلنا إليه مرتين
وأتيناه ثلاث مرات ونفكر فيه
على الرقبة وجذوع البنادق وضجيج الدبابات أكثر
بضعة أيام ح بضعة أيام أخرى، وهكذا، ويمكن
أن يكون على الأقل في تجربة الضغط العسكري الشخير
الرياء ليس دراماتيكيًا كما لو سمح له بذلك
تسعة أيام لنفسه لا يرد جوابا، ولا حتى واحدا
كتابةً، لا لنا، ولا لإسرائيل، إلى مدى القاطرة ومصر
يبدو أنه يشعر أن لديه الوقت ليضيعه
ومع ذلك، فهذه مسألة ينبغي أن تزعجني
لنا أيضا في جانب الجواب السلبي إذا كان الأمر كذلك
ويأتي ما تفعله إسرائيل بإجابة سلبية
كيف تتوقع أن يصاب صاحب المنزل بالجنون؟
لا أستطيع التوفيق على الإطلاق مع ما أصاب صاحب المنزل بالجنون
أسأل نفسي هذه الأسئلة والآن
نحن معك ميك كوبي، عضو بارز سابق في شابات إيش
الذي درس لمدة 10 ساعات
السنوار
يواصل السنوار خداع الجمهور الإسرائيلي و
السنوار يتصرف تمامًا كما عرفته في المرة الأخيرة
السنوار الأول هو الساحر السنوار
لن يشتري أبدًا، سيفعل أي شيء يؤذيه
بالنسبة لدولة إسرائيل، هؤلاء هم شباب السنوار، كما قرأت
رأيته، جلست معه، أكلت معه
أنا أعرف سلوكياته لذلك أنا
أريد أن أفتح وأطلب منكم فرع جوندر د مصلح
لقد استولت على السنوار في السجن كما عرفته
شخصياً، ما الذي يتعين على إسرائيل القيام به للقضاء على هذه المشكلة
هذا الرجل الذي يرفض السماح لك بالرحيل
وعلى إسرائيل المختطفة أن تسعى إلى تدميره
لا يوجد شيء آخر لا ينبغي إدارته مع الوقت والوقت
إنه يعرفنا جيدًا، ويعرف الحساسيات
لدينا نقاط ضعفنا وهو يستخدمها
لنا درس سيكولوجية الشارع
الإسرائيلي وبعد أن يسمعه الإعلام
الإسرائيلي ما بثناه له نحن
لقد أعطوه المزيد من الهواء ليتنفسه
في فريق مع عوفر ديكل وعدد قليل من الأصدقاء الآخرين من الجيش
الناخبون من الجيش الذين حاولوا بطريقة أو بأخرى توحيد صفوفهم
نوع من خطة العمل لمحاولة تقليل
قائمة الإرهابيين وقال بشكل لا لبس فيه شيئا
لن تحركنا عما سنقرره أي شيء
كل هذه ستكون شجيرات السنور يوم يطلقه
وسيؤكد لهم أنه سيتم إدراجهم في قوائمه القادمة
متى سيتفاوض معه
وعلق وزير الدفاع الإسرائيلي غالانت اليوم خلال
تصريحه لقضية اليوم التالي لسليما الأول
أعود إليك ومن بين أمور أخرى أيضًا انتقاد اللغة بهذه الطريقة
في لغة القانون، يتعرض رئيس الوزراء لانتقادات أكثر
تالي ضمنا وزير الدفاع جالانت على رأسه
حكومة بنيامين نتنياهو وبالمناسبة ليست المرة الأولى
الأول في قضية مهمة جدًا أيضًا للنظام
أما الأمن، بالمناسبة، على المستوى السياسي، وكذلك على المستوى الأميركي
أولئك الذين يضغطون على إسرائيل لقبول القرار يعتمدون على الكلمات
بخصوص مسألة اليوم التالي في غزة وانتبهوا للأمور
وهو ما قاله وزير الدفاع اليوم خلال تلك الحفلة
الصحفيون: العمل العسكري لا يتطلب سوى عمل سياسي
إن الترويج لبديل مدني سيضمن القضاء عليه
حماس في غزة، يقول الشيء نفسه عن الإنجازات
ويجب أيضاً أن يُستكمل الجيش بتحركات سياسية
ويضيف أن حماس لن تحكم القطاع، بل العوامل هي التي ستحكمه
المواطنين وفي الواقع تالي لديه خطة أعدها النظام
وزير الدفاع جانيت هاتزل المتمركز بالفعل في المستوى
السياسي في الحكومة منذ شهر تقريبا ورئيس الوزراء
ومازلت لم أطرح هذا القرار أو أي قرار
خلاف ذلك أو أي خطة أخرى لموافقة مجلس الوزراء
بالطبع، أولا وقبل كل شيء خوفا من الأمور السياسية هناك
العديد من الوزراء في الحكومة ضد هذا الشيء
ونحن نرى كيف بدأ تأثيره بالفعل
في الميدان عندما تكون حماس في شمال قطاع غزة تبدأ ببطء
بطيء في العودة ثم مرة أخرى في شعاع SEG
تأكد من الصوت في هذا الشأن، هوم، الرسالة إلى الرأس
الكلمة